ce lundi à bangkok des milliers de
manifestants bravent pour la cinquième
journée consécutive
l'interdiction de rassemblements de plus
de cinq personnes
avant de se disperser dans le calme ils
ont une nouvelle fois réclamé la
démission du premier ministre et une
réforme de la monarchie
je ne pense pas qu'on venant ici
aujourd'hui la monarchie prendra fin
pendant ma génération l on pourrait au
moins essayer de les amener à un système
démocratique sous la constitution
je n'ai pas peur parce que la peur est
ce que le gouvernement et le premier
ministre veulent susciter chez le peuple
si nous avons peur d'eux ils en
profiteront davantage c'est pourquoi je
voudrais leur dire que plus ils
utiliseront la violence contre nous plus
nous utiliserons la paix la pureté dans
la lutte contre la violence
un peu plus tôt dans la journée le chef
du gouvernement thaïlandais prayut
chan-o-cha avait annoncé la réunion en
session extraordinaire du parlement pour
je cite résoudre ce conflit
mais les tensions de vendredi dernier où
la police a évacué les protestataires à
l'aide de canons à eau et procéder à une
série d'interpellations n'ont pas
dissuadé la contestation une
contestation débuté il ya déjà trois
mois mais qui connaît depuis plusieurs
jours une nouvelle ampleur après le
passage mercredi dernier du convoi de la
reine suited à devant des manifestants
qui lui ont alors fait le salut à trois
doigts un signe directement inspirée des
films à succès hunger games et
symbolisant désormais l'opposition
gouvernement parmi les demandes des
manifestants
l'abrogation de la loi de lèse majesté
punissant de 3 à 15 ans de prison
toute diffamation insulte envers le
monarque et sa famille ou encore la non
ingérence du souverain thaïlandais dans
les affaires politiques du pays
mais surtout le départ du premier
ministre un ancien général
porté au pouvoir par un coup d'état en
ce que le gouvernement doit faire ses
protégés la monarchie c'est le devoir de
chaque thaïlandais nous faisons de notre
mieux pour éviter d'utiliser la force
mais nous vous demandons de ne facilitez
aucune action qui pourrait mener à ce
point
la police dit avoir arrêté 74 personnes
depuis le 13 octobre
19 ont été libérés sous caution ce lundi
outre les arrestations
un média liée à l'ancien premier
ministre en exil thaksin shinawatra a
été interdit de diffusion
une pression qui semble avoir son effet
ils n'étaient que quelques centaines à
manifester ce mardi